ustedes se imaginan que el internet de
repente dejará de funcionar con la caída
de esta red de una forma permanente o
por un largo periodo la manera de vivir
en nuestro mundo actual tendría que
cambiar drásticamente lo contrario no
Sería posible continuar con nuestro modo
de vida en un mundo Cada vez más
digitalizado estamos realmente
preparados para un escenario como este
como esto nos afectaría y nos cambiaría
estaríamos cerca de una caída masiva del
internet pues se lo preguntamos a
nuestra primera invitada del día Ella es
Esther Paniagua periodista y escritora
española especializada en ciencia y
tecnología Esther muy buena tarde ya
para usted Gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana del jueves aquí en
el continente americano la primera
pregunta que le quiero hacer es que si
realmente estamos preparados frente a
una posible caída Real del internet que
colapse a nivel global
Buenas tardes gracias por la invitación
no es una pregunta retórica Claro que no
estamos preparados no y es algo muy
Obvio o tal vez no tanto porque a veces
no somos conscientes de cuán
dependientes somos de la red de redes y
no hablo solo de nuestra dependencia
emocional que está claro que dependemos
de la conectividad para las
comunicaciones personales Y para nuestra
vida incluso nuestro ocio sino de la
dependencia sistémica y cuando hablo de
dependencias sistémica pues hablo de que
Prácticamente todo está conectado está
estamos convirtiendo todo en un
ordenador no y y incluyendo
infraestructuras críticas con una
electricidad servicios críticos de
hospitales servicios médicos las
administraciones públicas las empresas
entonces no estamos preparados para
funcionar sin la conectividad y una
caída Pues podría ser muy catastrófica
claro Esther ante esto podemos pensar en
un mundo con un sistema de
funcionamiento híbrido es decir no
depender solamente del internet para
poder funcionar nosotros o como sociedad
podemos hacer también una analogía con
lo que ocurre en la guerra en Ucrania
actualmente la dependencia sobre todo de
los europeos de los hidrocarburos o
rusos para su energía Mire lo que está
pasando Cuando solo depende uno de algo
para poder funcionar entonces podemos
plantearnos un mundo con una dualidad de
funcionamiento ante una caída del
internet digamos
Bueno la verdad es que es difícilmente
planteable porque lo que está conectado
se puede desconectar por supuesto
requeriría mucho esfuerzo y Habría que
ver en que en qué casos tiene sentido
hacerlo y en qué casos no no Por ejemplo
si hay tenemos infraestructuras críticas
como los recursos energéticos conectadas
y no podemos protegerlas adecuadamente
con lo que he requerido Entonces sí
debemos plantearnos desconectarlas ahora
bien hay otros elementos Pues que tal
vez no conviene pero sí que debemos
asegurarnos de que están protegidos cosa
que no está sucediendo porque no sé no
se invierte por lo general no lo
suficiente en ciberseguridad y tampoco
hay la concienciación adecuada entre
empleados y entre la población no porque
al final el elemento humano es el
elemento más importante somos el punto
débil de la cadena y y la mayoría de los
hidrataques más de un 90% se producen
Gracias a que hay una interacción humana
en el último paso en el que hay una
persona que hace clic en el enlace
adecuado incorrecto o que descarga un
programa con un virus malicioso que
desencadena eso no hemos visto además en
relación con la guerra con la invasión
Mejor dicho no de Rusia sobre Ucrania
que se están atacando Bueno desde el
principio de esta ciberguerra que
también es una guerra híbrida se están
atacando infraestructuras
de Electricidad europeas aunque no se
han atribuido responsabilidades aún por
esos ciberataques también hemos visto
como de hecho se están bueno ha habido
fallos y problemas en cables submarinos
en zonas en las que casualmente hay
buques pesqueros rusos y recordemos que
los cables submarinos llevan el 99 99%
del tráfico mundial de internet no con
lo cual un ataque a estos cables que son
muchos obviamente no cada país suele
tener más de uno para que haya
redundancia pero atacar estos cables
también significa la desconexión de
internet no Y también obviamente pues
sabemos que a través de internet se
puede se puede atacar la infraestructura
eléctrica comentabais antes El que se
está bueno pues habiendo muchos
problemas no en Ucrania por la falta de
Electricidad ya en 2015 Rusia
desconectó de la red eléctrica Ucrania a
través de un cierre ataque lo repitió en
2016 hoy en día es verdad que no no les
hace falta No recurrir a la ciber guerra
para esta desconexión ya que se puede
hacer A través de el elemento es mucho
más básicos No claro Bombas o ataques
físicos estamos hablando Esther en este
caso de todos estos agentes externos
Pero qué pasaría cuando un el gobierno
como también lo hemos visto por ejemplo
en Irán regímenes autoritarios cuando
cortan cuando bloquean el servicio de
internet porque los ciudadanos Todavía
no Estamos protegidos digamos una una
ley global para el derecho a la
conectividad del derecho a la
información y pues a estar conectados en
esta red si este es un muy buen punto de
hecho es algo que se viene reclamando
desde hace mucho tiempo no el derecho a
la conectividad porque precisamente por
eso se ha convertido en algo tan básico
y tan básico para derechos para mantener
derechos como el de la libertad de
expresión la libertad de movimiento la
libertad de reunión y de organización no
por eso países como Irán ante estos
momentos de revuelta
censuran internet pasa y sigue pasando y
se queda pasando también en la India en
la casemira India en 2019 hubo una
desconexión de 7 meses de la internet
que fue la desconexión más larga en una
democracia y a pesar de que fue algo
voluntario por parte del gobierno y que
estaban entre comillas preparados para
ellos claro nadie está preparado para el
caos que se produce hubo pérdidas
económicas millonarias Pero obviamente
no solo eso sino afectación en la vida
diaria de las personas que no podían
circular con normalidad no podían pagar
facturas no podían hacer compras con
normalidad relacionarse con la gente
trabajar
muchas empresas tuvieron que cerrar
accidentes industriales y un largo
etcétera de problemas no Sí este ya ya
Para ir cumpliendo nuestra conversación
porque Lamentablemente se me acaba el
tiempo pero no quiero que se me queden
estos dos puntos que le quiero preguntar
por fuera si todas estas condiciones no
mejoran como ve el futuro próximo de el
internet y además podemos estar frente
si ante una caída masiva de un escenario
digamos apocalíptico
a ver la caída masiva puede suceder No
es fácil pero es algo de lo que ya se
lleva advirtiendo mucho tiempo desde la
comunidad técnica no Y además puede
suceder por un mero error ni siquiera
tiene que ser debido a un ciber ataque y
el problema es que no nos estamos
preparando para esto a nivel
gubernamental ni supernacional no hay
planes de cómo funcionarse en internet y
lo estamos viendo cuando hay ciber
ataques bueno acá en España Supongo que
por allá cuando pasa no hay en ciber
ataque que hace que tengamos que
desconectar nuestros servicios por
ejemplo los de una empresa o los de
France 24 por ejemplo no Bueno pues si
no hubiera internet no habría planes en
esta en su empresa imagino para cómo
funcionar de forma analógica no esto
obviamente a nivel gubernamental tampoco
existe y es un gran problema no
precisamente porque los ciberataques
están a la orden del día no y también
hay otro mensaje que a mí me gustaría
lanzar y es el hecho de que también esta
que tenemos de la conectividad viene
dada por la centralización de la web no
al final cuando hablo de internet muchas
veces me refiero también a la web que
son al final los contenidos no los que
accedemos lo que lo que nos importa y
esa centralización en unas pocas grandes
empresas tecnológicas hace que un ataque
contra ellas también haga que toda la
internet si es un ataque coordinado
contra por ejemplo Amazon Google y los
servidores de alojamiento de contenido
en Nube también se caería no de forma
efectiva entonces necesitamos mecanismo
de gobernanza supranacional que obligue
a reforzar las medidas de seguridad y a
implementar otras nuevas que hacen falta
Yo en mi libro hago más de 75 propuestas
no es cuestión de citarlas todas aquí
pero necesitamos esto obviamente estos
nuevos derechos Como el derecho a la
conectividad Y ser conscientes como
ciudadanos es el primer paso para exigir
el cambio político Esther muy lejos
también en Qué pasa cuando se cae a lo
mejor el WhatsApp o el Instagram